the sea may look inviting
the sand a pleasant sight but the
beaches have been
shut in the city of durban the tourists
know where to be seen as a virulent
strain of covid 19
tears through this community
we know it as the south african variant
and it was discovered here i'm
excited as a scientist i am tired as a
human being
the scientists call it 501 yv2
and they believe this strain has fueled
a giant
second wave of infections in south
africa
why we got much busier on the middle end
of
november because we were responding by
calls of the clinical staff of one of
the main hospitals
in nelson mandela bay that saw a very
unusual increase
of new cases yeah and they were
convinced that probably was something
different about the virus so we answer
to the call very quick
once identified the team realized how
quickly it was spreading
across the country and into neighboring
african states
our lab crisp is receiving also samples
from botswana zimbabwe
zambia angola and malawi and in zambia
the last 23 genomes that they have done
22 of those
were these variants so the south african
variant
or the variant that we call the 501 v2
this is a worrying moment right across
the continent
south africa boasts modern
infrastructure but its clinics and
hospitals
have barely coped with the variant and
in other parts of africa
people are largely on their own do you
feel like you're pushing the alarm bell
here
in in durban yeah i mean that that's
certainly what we're
i mean we're certainly trying to push
the alarm bell and
trying to make this point that we need
help we need help
here in south africa we need help in the
region
and we need to make sure that people
understand about this point that this is
a global pandemic
and that if we leave africa and african
countries to try and deal with this
themselves we're going to have a big
problem on our hands
the team in durban know that vaccines
will be key
what they don't know is how effective
they'll be against south africa's hardy
fast spreading variant we watched a
researcher
put the university of oxford's vaccine
to the test
we somewhat underestimated uh this virus
and of course now we're checking
something very similar
with the woody vaccines and the results
should be coming out shortly
okay and what does shortly mean it's uh
i mean
it's it means weeks no one in south
africa
is underestimating the virus anymore
for there is a view that we may be
closer to the beginning
than the end john sparks sky news
durban